بدون ادنى شك هي تحركات مشابهه راويه فحمى
التودد الى افريقيا اصابت الصين ايضا
والامر ليس وليد اليوم وانما يعود لسنوات
طويله مضت وهو ما تعكسه معطيات عده اخرها
زياره وزير الخارجيه الصيني الجديد
لعده دول افريقيه في اوائل مهامه وهو
تقليد صني معتاد منذ ثلاثه عقوده ويظهر
الاهميه الكبيره التي تليها بكين لافريقيا
عسكريا ايضا فان الصين تملك قاعدتها
العسكريه الوحيده في الخارج تحديدا في
دوله جيبوتي الواقعه في شرق افريقيا وذلك
منذ العام 2017 كما ان العديد من وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه اشارت الى وجود مشروع
صينيه لاقامه قاعده عسكريه في غرب افريقيا
وتحديدا في غينيا الاستوائيه الواقعه على
ساحل المحيط الاطلسي
اما تجاريا فحدث ولا حرج الصين هي اكبر
شريك تجاري للقاره الافريقيه بحيث يبلغ
حجم تبادل تجاري بلغ في العام الماضي على
الاقل
254 مليار دولار ومن دون شك فان التقارب
الصينيه الروسيه الافريقي لا يروق كثيرا
للولايات المتحده التي بدات تتحرك لمواجهه
هذا التغلغل واشنطن بادرت بارسال وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه جانيت يلد في جوله
افريقيه لاعاده احياء علاقاتها مع افريقيا
التي شهدت نوعا من الفطور في السنوات
القليله الماضيه تاتي زياره بعد سته اشهر
من اعلان الولايات المتحده عن استراتيجيه
جديده تهدف الى التدارك سنوات من الاهمال
لقاره افريقيا علما انا واشنطن استضافت
قمه افريقيا شهر الماضي
الرغبه في مواجهه التغلغل الروسي والصيني
في القاره بدجليا في تصريحات وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه التي القت باللوم على
روسيا في تفاقم المشاكل الاقتصاديه
لافريقيا كما وجهت انتقادا منفصلا للصين
بسبب ممارستها
الاقراضيه ويبقى السؤال هل تاخرت واشنطن